[Music]
now that is Bryan Cranston doing his
best Kevin Hart now I'm sure you're
asking why is Bryan imitating Kevin well
a funny thing happened when those two
guys got together to make their new
movie untouchable an unlikely bromance
broke out it's a love story between two
straight men Ryan likes me so let's just
let's just stop here what's not to like
these two became fast friends working on
the film where Kevin plays caretaker to
Bryan's wheelchair-bound millionaire
what's it been like working with Kevin
and forming that bond with him you and I
have have have drawn close do we really
have we become friends guy is hyper
discipline and yeah but he comes in he
makes people laugh he just lifts lifts
the spirits of the set to where the long
hours still long but a little little
easier Bryan your new name is cryo be
higher cryo be as in cryotherapy
untouchable we'll be out later this year
and even co-star Nicole Kidman has
noticed the sparks between these two
they're both amazing I'm so lucky I have
a supporting role in this so I get to
stand back and watch the two of them
have this
no chemistry together so those two
together I sit back and go whoo but
there might be trouble in paradise
because Brian's impression of Kevin has
gone viral but Brian Christie said
that's how you reacted when you found
out that your wife was pregnant you know
what
first of all Ryan's got some nerves
all right look that was confidential
okay things that I'll talk to you bye
Brian
between you and I now to find out you
got this impression running around the
town and people are talking about and
that's not the only secret Brian is
sharing about Kevin
he takes little cat naps on the set he
works himself so hard he'll sit down on
a chair and just not taking that
everything questions in between are they
and I and I woke up that fast Kevin
really is the businessman in Hollywood
you